new insights are coming to light this
morning in the deadly arrest of george
floyd
one of the four former minneapolis
police officers charged in his death is
speaking out
and revealing his belief that floyd's
ability to speak was a sign that he was
still able to breathe
we do want to warn you some of what
you're about to see is disturbing errol
barnett reports
one week after george floyd was killed
in police custody
one of the former officers charged in
his death gave this voluntary interview
to investigators
it was obvious to me that he was like
high on something
officer two tau says after floyd
resisted being placed into a police
vehicle
seen here on tao's newly released body
camera footage come on out
he suggested restraining him on the
ground
i can't breathe please
so that maneuver that you saw officer
shavin is that something you've been
trained in
uh i've never used it have you ever seen
officer shavon do that before in calls
i don't recall tao's body camera also
shows he
ignored floyd's pleas if they're talking
they're breathing obviously and for the
first time we hear tao's reaction to the
news of floyd's death
yeah i i don't want anyone here to die
me it was kind of a somber moment
my heart kind of sank benjamin crump is
the floyd family attorney
where was compassion where was the
regret then watching another human being
being literally tortured to death
for cbs this morning saturday i'm errol
barnett